oh I just wanna paint the town crazy
[Music]
gospel man yes I know I am late on this
I technical issues again and I consider
doing this as a double feature with the
next episode that's coming out but I
decided they have been building this one
up a lot I wanted to deal with it in
isolation given that by the end of it it
was largely a setup episode I kind of
wish it as a double feature instead but
you know what can you do so we are gonna
talk about the mandatory brunch meeting
so this one very jerome focused and i
knew that going in and spoilers at this
point the episodes even been out for a
while so i don't know why you're
watching this if you if you care about
spoilers but the twist of him having a
brother unfortunately was something that
i didn't know for certain but I suspect
it already and it it's a reaffirmation
of why I avoid fan theory as much as
humanly possible
I wasn't even somewhere where I should
have been seeing it but I read a news
article about the latest trailer they
came out and just in the body of that
article above the trailer they mentioned
some fans are speculating that he has a
twin brother and yeah that's what I
ended up being happening and
unfortunately I can't judge how well
this would have worked if I hadn't seen
it coming because I kind of did and I I
don't even know if I would have figured
that out or guessed that as a
possibility on my own I'd like to think
maybe I could have but again I will
never know because I hate fan theory so
that was a little bit of an outburst
calming down so setting aside the fact
that I knew the twist was coming how is
this overall well not quite as much
Jerome as I thought based on the lead-up
but find Jerome very fun this whole
thing of
he opens up the question again as to who
is the Joker because I think we had all
just kind of been assuming well Jerome's
the Joker duh but now he's got a brother
so now flip a coin could go either way
and it would it would not be that big of
a leap to say that you know he's going
to torture his brother until his brother
is crazy
and there's our Joker so that's a
possibility it's not a huge investment
to me either way it's a it's an
interesting option again setting aside
the fact that it's not a it's not a
surprise me anymore it's an interesting
option because it can give us something
where no we haven't actually been seeing
the Joker all this time that doesn't
feel like as much of a cheat as it might
have otherwise cuz the gut Jerome was so
coded as Joker that you know to do a
clean break and have it just be somebody
else completely what it felt like well
that's just then what was the point of
that but to have it be his twin brother
like OK in the world of Gotham yeah sure
let's roll with that as far as the other
villains they were largely just kind of
there you know scarecrow and Mad Hatter
and Firefly and in mr. Freeze's they're
just kind of there and now I suspect
that some of them are gonna be featured
a little bit more in the follow-up
episode we've got we've got Grundy
hooking up with with penguin which is
that's kind of it just think haven't
seen butch and and Oswald together in a
while and now they've got that barrel of
stuff that helped turn Grundy it turned
butch into Grundy so I suspect that is
going to be involved in the creation of
the Joker if nothing else it could end
up being what bleaches his skin so
there's my little prediction that and
that's not even like a fan theory that's
just like I'm looking at what they're
setting up this seems kind of obvious to
me if that is fan theory they just boil
stuff for you I'm sorry you have every
reason to get as mad at me as I got at
yet that website for putting that that
other one up as far as the other stuff
going along go
on not not at the whole thing with the
Riddler and Lee I don't I honestly don't
know what to think about that I don't
know if I like it or not like just
straight up I don't know and I feel like
I need to see I need to see an episode
of what that actually looks like cuz
unlike say at nas Wald huh I wasn't
actually shipping Lee and and at Orly
and the Riddler you know in my mind I
wasn't actually going oh those good
those two together would be great so and
nor did it really occur to me as a
legitimate possibility even after there
was like the hints that he was that at
the head side of his personality was
starting to fall for leave that to me
struck me as an insular thing and was
his issue and maybe it still is maybe
honestly she's just playing him because
she understands that side of him well
enough could be but that's kind of my
point I need to know a little bit more
about this dynamic how genuine is this
thing that's between them and how does
it actually work and once I see it
trying to function however it's gonna
function I think I'll be able to make it
clean or calm whether or not I like this
cuz right now I'm just kind of like ah
that was an odd turn of events so not
sure there's too much else beyond that
it is really good just having Jim and
Harvey you know together again just sort
of rolling along that those who really
do bounce off each other particularly
well I'm mom and I'm enjoying Bruce for
the little bit that we got him I guess I
only talk about his existence talking
about the Jerome's brother Jeremiah he's
kind of interesting it well first of all
it's an interesting showcase for the
actor cuz it gets to show him doing
something completely different and being
fairly convincing at it and also that I
do appreciate the little hints that we
get that Jeremiah is not as innocent
as he certainly wants Jim and Harvey to
think that he is I finally say I haven't
like done a google search whatever for a
Batman character called echo I'm
wondering what her deal is whether or
not she was something they created for
the show or whether she's gonna end up
being like a proto Harley Quinn or
something I don't know I wasn't sure
what to make of her the whole ninja you
know assistant thing yeah I don't know
but it was fun getting there
unfortunately like the whole buildup of
this thing because I I and I was
basically going in my head the whole
time uh-huh just don't be a twin just
don't be the twin just don't be too not
cuz it's a bad idea it's a fine idea I
just wanted to be surprised yeah you
know I did I didn't want to already know
well what can you do
so um you know now we've gotten this
buildup and I I definitely want to see
you where things go from here I am
curious and why I want to see what
Jerome hasn't has planned what he has in
store what he's going to be bringing out
of his brother because I think it has
the potential to be very entertaining so
those are my thoughts on the episode of
Gotham from last week that I didn't
review when it came out hopefully I've
got my technical issues sorted out and
and and I won't be missing because of
stuff like that anymore so Gotham the
mandatory brunch meeting what are your
thoughts about it wherever they are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's all the stuff to do
such as support me on patreon like
subscribe follow me on Twitter etc etc
etc links for all this stuff is down in
the description so until next time the
brunch meeting is adjourned
[Laughter]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]